[Música]
Olá é um prazer estar contigo aqui de
novo esse vídeo é fundamental nos tempos
atuais é sobre prevenção de coágulos
sanguíneos vocês repararam como é que
aumentou nos últimos tempos na forma de
trombose infarto e AVC eu tenho
desconfiado de uma razão mas como eu não
tenho certeza eu prefiro não dizer hoje
Vamos explorar O que são os coágulos Por
que que eles se formam Quais são os
fatores de risco e mais importante como
você pode prevenir a ocorrência de
coágulos para manter sua saúde em dia
bem vamos começar dizendo o que são
coagulos sanguíneos os coagulos
sanguíneos são massas semilíquidas
formadas pela agregação de plaquetas e
proteínas do sangue como fibrinogênio
eles desempenham um papel Vital na
prevenção de hemorragias quando tem uma
lesão quando tem um machucado nos vasos
sanguíneos seja veia seja artéria No
entanto quando os coágulos se formam de
forma inadequada de maneira inadequada
dentro dos vasos eles vão obstruir o
fluxo sanguíneo isso vai levar sérias
complicações de saúde Então por que que
os coágulos se formam a coagulação é um
processo natural importantíssimo
essencial paraa cicatrização de feridas
contudo todavia certos fatores podem
desencadear a formação excessiva de
coágulos mesmo na ausência de lesões
Entre esses fatores nós destacamos
estagnação de sangue quando o sangue não
circula de forma adequada a maior
probabilidade de formação de coágulos
danos nas paredes dos vasos lesões nos
vasos sanguíneos podem iniciar o
processo de coagulação de uma maneira
inadequada aumento a propensão à
coagulação tem algumas condições médicas
alguns problemas de saúde e também
genéticas que aumentam até tendência do
sangue A coagular então vamos falar dos
fatores de risco paraa formação de
coágulos conhecer os fatores de risco é
muito importante é fundamental paraa
prevenção eficaz desses coágulos
sanguíneos então vamos conhecer alguns
dos principais o primeiro deles é
imobilidade prolongada por exemplo
viagens longas de avião ou repouso
absoluto no leito Você pode ter
problemas isso vai aumentar o risco de
trombose venosa profunda que geralmente
começa nas pernas nas coxas coloca aqui
embaixo nos comentários se você sabe que
é trombose e se você quer que eu faça um
vídeo mais aprofundado a respeito Outro
fator cirurgias recentes procedimentos
cirúrgicos especialmente ortopédicos
podem predispor a formação de coágulos
várias condições médicas doenças como
câncer doenças cardíacas doenças
hormonais especialmente o uso de
contraceptivos né os anticoncepcionais
orais ou mesmo terapia de reposição
hormonal feita de forma não Idêntica não
bioidêntica não isomolecular pessoas
podem ter também histórico familiar ter
antecedentes familiares de distúrbios de
coagulação também obesidade o excesso de
peso aumenta a pressão nas veias das
pernas isso vai contribuir pra formação
de coágulos o ato de fumar o tabagismo
fumar prejudica a circulação sanguínea e
aumenta a espessura do sangue a idade
avançada também é um fator pessoas com
idade mais avançada mais de 60 anos de
idade estão mais suscetíveis a
desenvolver os coágulos algumas
tecnologias recentes Talvez tenham a ver
com isso muitos jovens têm sido tolhidos
de nosso convívio de forma precoce
estranha abatidos por doenças típicas de
idosos Mas isso é só uma suspeita Tem
surgido alguns estudos sobre a
possibilidade das tecnologias novas
terem a ver com o aumento de trombose
atual eu prefiro que você forme a sua
própria ideia sobre esse tipo de assunto
que você estude sobre esse tema procure
estudar se informar sobre isso então
coloca aqui nos comentários Você conhece
alguém que tenha nos deixado cedo demais
por causa de infarto trombose ou AVC
coloca aqui nos comentários bem vamos
falar de estratégia de prevenção agora
que entendemos os fatores de risco vamos
abordar as principais estratégias para
prevenir a formação de coagru meos um
movimente-se regularmente não fica
sentado o tempo todo na cadeira para
quem passa muitos longos períodos
sentado como em viagens ou mesmo
trabalhando é fundamental levantar-se
periodicamente uma vez a cada uma hora
pelo menos por 10 minutos faça pausas
para caminhar a cada hora nem que seja
uma caminhada bem curta exercício de
alongamento fazer movento simples das
pernas e tornozelos para estim
circulação dois Mantenha o peso Saudável
Tenha também três Uma alimentação
balanceada adotar uma dieta rica em
frutas vegetais fibras proteínas
saudáveis gorduras saudáveis e uma dieta
baixa em gorduras artificiais alimentos
processados industrializados e
carboidratos
refinados próximo item atividade física
regular praticar exercícios físicos
ajuda a controlar o peso e melhorar a
circulação sanguínea hidratação adequada
beba água suficientemente mantenha-se
hidratado isso evita que o seu sangue se
torne Grosso espesso Isso facilita a
circulação próximo item evite fumar
Evite o tabagismo parar de fumar melhora
sua saúde vascular e reduz
significativamente o risco de coágulos
cinco uso de medicações
preventivas uso de anticoagulantes em
casos de alto risco é judicado médicos
podem prescrever anticoagulantes para
prevenir a coagulação excessiva existem
alguns naturais como é o caso de
natoquinase lumbrokinase serra peptase
picnogenol eles podem ajudar muito e tem
Menos efeitos colaterais bem menos então
assistam os meus vídeos sobre isso tá
vou deixar aqui o link no primeiro
comentário e na descrição Você já usou
anticoagulantes naturais como Nat kinas
pequino genol conte para nós a sua
experiência aqui nos comentários avalie
cuidadosamente os riscos benefício com o
seu médico com seu profissional de saúde
antes de iniciar uma terapia de
reposição hormonal e só utilize os
hormônios bioidênticos isom moleculares
porque eles têm a mesma composição do
nosso corpo próximo item adapte-se ao
ambiente vestuário apropriado use meias
de compressão em viagens longas ou se
você estiver predisposto a problemas de
circulação evite calor excessivo o calor
pode dilatar os seus vasos sanguíneos e
aumentar o risco de coagulação exagerada
próximo item controle de condições
médicas gerenciamento de doenças
crônicas é fundamental manter condições
como diabetes hipertensão arterial
doenças cardíacas sob controle é muito
importante especialmente Com
acompanhamento
médico monitoramento regular realize
exames periódicos para
detectar e tratar precocemente qualquer
anomalia que você tiver na coagulação
sanguínea através de exames regulares
bem pessoal quais são os sintomas então
dos coágulos exagerados é crucial Estar
atento ou atenta aos sinais que indicam
a presença de um coágulo sanguíneo
primeiro sinal dor e inchaço
principalmente nas pernas acompanhado de
vermelhidão ou calor na região
dificuldade respiratória Então pode
sinalizar um coágulo nos pulmões
conhecido como embolia pulmonar dor no
peito ou mal digestão sinais de que o
coágulo pode de ter atingido o coração
ou sistema digestório tontura ou desmaio
indicativos que possa ter acontecido uma
possível coagulação no cérebro como em
caso de AVC então concluindo pessoal a
prevenção de coagulos sanguíneos é uma
combinação de hábitos saudáveis
conscientização dos fatores de risco e
quando necessário o uso de medicações
preventivas Sob orientação médica sejam
naturais ou sejam de farmácia comum ao
adotar um estilo de vida ativo manter
uma alimentação equilibrada evitar o
tabagismo e controlar condições médicas
você pode reduzir
significativamente o risco de formação
de coágulos e proteger a sua saúde a
longo prazo lembre-se sempre de
consultar um bom profissional de saúde
um médico ou médica para orientações
personalizadas e adequadas à suas
necessidades estude sobre as tecnologias
novas e as possibilidades que estão
sendo publicadas em estudos recentes que
apontam que talvez eu digo somente
talvez tenham algo a ver com esse surto
recente de trombos e coágulos você é
feira um grande abraço e um beijo no seu
coração compartilhe os vídeos façil bem
a vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal da alvar